yeah oh it Joe was always a pleasure to
be with him she hasn't seen the film yet
but I've told her this is probably going
to be her favorite film that I've ever
done my whole family's from Italy and
and so Hayden so half Italian quarter
Italian yeah
is a no I mean I think people are
partial to anchovies but for me I can't
do it so I have to avoid anchovies at
all costs yeah they're making a comeback
at the moment you know I think it's it's
a reflection of what's going on our
culture and just sort of a desire and an
appetite for these types of stories
right now and you know I think this will
hopefully be the start of seeing some
more of these things right now yeah do
you buy that yeah well we both have
little ones like you know I have a
soon-to-be four year old daughter and
paw patrol and jake and the neverland
pirates and all the kid shows that's
like you know what dominates my TV these
days
yeah
I don't know if I have any advice for
that but just you know don't take it too
seriously because unfortunately those
are the ones that make the most noise
but the majority that people don't feel
that way so keep that in mind